with the first pick in the 1996 NBA
draft the Philadelphia 76ers select
Allen Iverson from Georgetown University
and there you see backstage Allen
Iverson the Georgetown sophomore
wearing the Hat of the Philadelphia
76ers
Allen Iverson
congratulations huby Brown says there's
nobody in the league quicker than you is
there anybody that can stop you
one-on-one I don't know I hope not I
don't think so
pretty well been able to do whatever you
want on the court in high school and in
college what have the Sixers told you
they expect from you
um they just want me to come in and play
my game
um you know distributed ball it's great
players already on the team Stackhouse
and Derrick Coleman um it'll be crazy to
think that I will come in and try to
take all the shots with the second pick
in the 1996 NBA draft
the Toronto Raptors select Marcus Camby
from the University of Massachusetts
there's the guy Rick Pitino said should
have gone first he'll take number two
though again with Marcus Camby there's
his mom Janice backstage and there's big
Marcus what position your talents where
they suited in the NBA
um people question you know what
position I'll play it three four to five
I can see myself just as a player just
get me out there on the court and just
let me play
with the third pick in the 1996 NBA
draft
the Vancouver Grizzlies select
Sharif Abdul Rahim from the University
of California
the earliest a freshman has ever gone in
the NBA draft Sharif Abdul Rahim
a high schooler in Marietta Georgia like
I was in a situation where I could um
really put my family in a better
situation put myself in a better
situation you know just fulfill a
lifetime dream
um
just have to go ahead and do that fourth
pick in the 1996 NBA draft
the Milwaukee Bucks select Stephon
Marbury from Georgia Tech University
the fourth pick of the draft the
Milwaukee Bucks takes Stefan Marbury
6-2-1-82 on a Georgia Tech
I can't even I can't even explain the
way I feel right now
it's been 20 years
20 long yes you waited for this date
and it's here it's here now
[Applause]
with the fifth pick in the 1996 NBA
draft the Minnesota Timberwolves select
Ray Allen from the University of
Connecticut
a parade of underclassmen continues here
in the first round Ray Allen the Junior
out of Uconn let's go into the NBA I
think I have to step it up a notch
everywhere
um I can't settle for set up for the
skills that I displayed in college I
think the NBA is another level and I
definitely have to improve a lot and
work very hard it's a sixth pick
in the 1996 NBA
in the University of Kentucky
I wish we had somebody on the set who
knew something about us
oh we do it has to become a little bit
more consistent shooter but a great
great competitor wants to beat you at a
game of horse with the 13th pick in the
1996 NBA draft
the Charlotte Hornets select Kobe Bryant
from Lower Marion High School in
Pennsylvania
every place that he worked out nothing
but Braves no one talking about any
shortness or a weakness in his game
Jerry West told me today that greatness
lies ahead for this young man oh it is a
step up from high school when I
understand that so therefore every time
I step on a basketball court I'm going
to put a strong effort out there on the
floor I'm going to I'm not gonna leave
anything floor
you're at the grades you had the scores
to go to college
why the NBA
challenge no 40 years old and I'm
sitting back and I'm looking back at my
career if I went to college and played
on NBA maybe I had a great career and
maybe not and I'm still having that down
my mind could have answered that
challenge could I have responded to the
challenge of the NBA and that's
something I didn't want to have on my on
my shoulders so I just really accepted
it let's talk about the word we're just
hearing the Peter Vesey reporting that
the Lakers could possibly be swinging a
deal with the Hornets for Kobe Bryant
kind of goes back to your Jerry West
conversation and speaking with Jerry
today was just raving about Kobe Bryant
and I was kidding him about speaking and
raving about Kobe to John Calipari so
please don't say anymore don't speak to
Johnny while we were kidding around and
he loves Kobe Bryant the 14th pick in
the 1996 NBA draft the Sacramento Kings
select pre-drag stojakovic from pow in
Greece
if he looks young he is he's 19 years
old just turned 19. who's playing some
ball in Greece
with the 15th pick in the 1996 NBA draft
the Phoenix Suns select Steve Nash from
the University of Santa Clara
Steve Nash the first Bronco to go in the
first round since when you asked 1969
but Ogden to Philadelphia you remember
that hereby I sure do as a matter of
fact one of my dearest friends Carl
Williams was an assistant coach honestly
it's just exciting for me to be here I
think that uh Santa Clara hasn't had a
pro since Ramis and it's exciting for
the school and I want to thank Santa
Clara St Michael's High School Arbutus
Junior High all my coaches my family and
my friends they've done a lot for me
along the way and I couldn't have done
it without any of them the 17th pick in
the 1996 NBA draft
the Portland Trailblazers select
Jermaine O'Neal from Eau Claire High
School in South Carolina
Jermaine is not here with the 20th pick
in the 1996 NBA draft
the Cleveland Cavaliers
select zedrunus ilgowskis from Lithuania
[Applause]
well with those two picks the Cleveland
Cavaliers definitely lead the league in
first round syllables zadrunus ilgauskas
of Lithuania Vitale potipenka was
already taken with a 12th pick in the
first round the 24th pick in the 1996
NBA draft the Los Angeles Lakers select
Derek Fisher from the University of
Arkansas at Little Rock